there's been a very small but very
significant change in the outlook for
the 2022 midterms over the last 48 hours
and that change is that for the first
time in these midterms by a very very
very small margin the 538 senate
forecast has democrats projected to hold
control of the united states senate and
this would be huge historically and it
would be huge practically because of
everything that's on the table looking
at 2022 and 2024 so we're going to go
through it piece by piece newsweek
noticing this with an article democrats
favor to win senate for first time as
polling improves per 538 and indeed when
we look at the 538 update
uh we now see that they correctly call
it a toss-up in the sense that the
margin is so small that you can't say it
is a big advantage for democrats but
the most likely scenario
uh of 100 outcomes is that democrats win
52 seats out of 100 which would actually
give democrats a bigger
um advantage in the senate than they
currently have remember currently it is
a 50 50 senate with kamala harris as the
tie-breaking vote as the vice president
who is the president of the senate in
cases of 50-50 doesn't do much for
democrats when you need 60 votes as you
do for many legislative activities but
it does make a significant um uh
it is an advantage it is a majority when
you have 50 50 situations now as we know
for 50 50 situations you need every
democrat on board including joe manchin
and kirsten cinema that is a story for a
different day which we have covered
extensively so what is what are the
repercussions what is the impact of this
uh let's first talk about historical
context number one
when a party wins the white house
taking it from the other party
in a presidential election
they almost always lose in the first
midterms so looking at a historical
precedent joe biden democrats took the
white house from trump and republicans
in 2020
democrats should lose and do poorly in
the november 22 midterms i think when we
spoke to political scientist rachel
bittikoffer on the show
she said that there's only like three
examples in history of where it went a
different way so if indeed democrats are
able to
retain control
expand the majority in the senate
um not lose power
that would already be historically
anomalous or anomalous
and it would um signify that something
different is taking place now what might
that something be there's two analyses
that are possible one would be
if democrats don't do terribly in
november it will be because of the
temporary trumpist constituency that
only cared about trump and now they've
bailed
and things have gone sort of back to
quote normal that would be one possible
analysis the other possible analysis
would be
that is not the explanation the
explanation would be democrats would
have lost
were it not for
roe v wade being overturned very
unpopular with americans
and nothing being done on gun safety
despite prominent mass shooting after
prominent mass shooting two issues
abortion and guns that are not typically
good issues for democrats in elections
this time around polling suggests might
actually be good issues now all of this
is hypothetical all of this is
if democrats manage to retain control
in one or both houses
and as you can see the margin is very
very very small so
this call it a 52 chance you know we can
interpret these numbers in a lot of
different ways and some of them are not
strictly speaking statistically accurate
but call it a 52 chance when i see 52
percent
i believe it is correct to call it a
toss-up and remember that hillary
clinton based on these models had an 85
chance of winning in 2016 the results
fell in the other 15 now it doesn't mean
that the estimates were wrong something
that's 85 percent likely to happen
might not happen but the point is when
we say 52 it's basically a coin flip and
it's going to come down to
who votes
who votes everyone must vote everyone
must vote and we are going to be
highlighting the key races on which
control of the senate could hinge there
are disagreements among some about
in particular right now is it more
important for democrats to keep control
of the house or keep control of the
senate on the senate the argument would
be more legislative in the house the
argument would be more about preventing
all of these bogus investigations into
joe biden into anthony fauci maybe even
into hunter biden why the house would
investigate hunter biden who has nothing
to do with the administration i still
couldn't tell you but there are
differing opinions about which
uh side of congress would be more
important to control i believe it is
both and uh no no race should be
conceded
no race should be ignored but we should
also be strategic particularly in the
senate because it's likely to hinge on
just a handful of races so if you want
to say this is good news you absolutely
can democrats should be losing
if you want to say it's bad news
you could also make that case and the
bad news would be
despite all of the abandonment of the
republican party of any substantive
policy despite the fact that they're not
even pretending to try to think about
being productive members of a
legislative body
they still might take control of the
senate and so you can find the good or
the bad in this as with most most cases
there's a little bit of both
but the opportunity is here
for
an unusual
event historically which is democrats
win the white house and they don't lose
control of everything in the next
midterms if you're using traditional
toilet paper and paper towels you're
probably cutting down trees from north
american old growth forest and i've
talked about before we don't want to be
doing that also they come wrapped in
single-use plastic that's also a mess
and the solution is real paper this is a
sponsor i feel great about real paper
makes paper towels and toilet paper from
fast-growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly it's a
major impact on carbon real paper also
uses no plastic packaging so we often
talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com
pacman the link is down below